[Music]
so recession is not just a state of mind
it is a measurable condition into which
an economy falls and here's how it has
always been defined by economists
recession is two consecutive quarters of
declining real gdp
in the first quarter of this year gdp
went down this week second quarter gdp
numbers will be released what will they
tell us
well here's a hint the white house just
released a statement quote while some
maintain that two consecutive quarters
of falling gdp constitute a recession
that is neither the official definition
nor the way economists evaluate the
state of the business cycle
really okay well we thought we would
talk to someone who's seen a lot of
business cycles
been in business event ramaswamy is
executive chairman and co-founder of
strive asset management which is a
fascinating new company he joins us
tonight
uh vic thanks so much for coming on so
you're in business um
what do you think of this new definition
of a recession
look it's like george orwell who said it
best right the best way to control a
society is to control its language first
and just like diversity is conformity
inclusion is exclusion war is peace now
apparently a recession is something
other than two consecutive quarters of
gdp decline now the thing i'll tell you
tucker is most sophisticated investors
in the market have already quietly
accepted the fact that we are in a
recession regardless of what this
administration says investors pay
attention to companies earnings just
look at walmart's disastrous report
earlier today where they slash their
profit expectations for the future so
investors aren't really going to pay
attention to what the administration
says they know what's really going on
but the thing to pay attention to here
is that it's not just the recession that
matters we are also facing rampant nine
plus percent inflation and in the market
you can either have recession without
inflation you could in principle have
nine plus percent inflation without a
recession it's a double whammy for us
right now we're facing both and
meanwhile the people in charge of this
administration are focusing on changing
the language that tells you a bit about
where their priorities are so the
walmart statement suggested they they
said recession is the reason that their
earnings will be short but they
suggested that maybe real recession is
higher than nine percent what do you
think that the real the actual
experience number is for people
well i think i think if you look at who
the everyday customer is at walmart
relative to a range of other businesses
that may be more insulated by other
forms of government subsidy or
protection this is where the everyday
american shops right so i think that you
have to look as a sophisticated market
observer you got to look at where the
real harbingers are and where the real
proxies are for the experience of the
everyday american and i think that the
real experience of inflation combined
with inflation that's driven by actually
high energy prices in this country
suggests that actually the experience of
most americans is even worse than the
numbers suggest but this administration
is just fixated on these band-aid
solutions like focusing on the language
we use to describe it rather than
addressing the problem of course
the vacrama swami a man who is
addressing problem we will see you again
appreciate you coming on tonight thank
you
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight